Jason Kenyon loves playing video games.
He thinks his love for the games is a notch below addiction.
His parents were concerned.
Well, to say the least, they didn't like it very much.
They said, "Stop it and focus on a real career."
But Jason thinks otherwise.
I am really sure it's a real career.
And I think, maybe when I'm finished with my bachelor's degree...
...probably two or so years from now,...
...I may be able to find work pretty easily compared to most other industries.
So, I think I'll have a good future.
Jason is one of a growing number of students...
...seeking careers in the video gaming and technology industry.
He is in the game development program at Montgomery College in Maryland.
Deborah Solomon is a professor there.
The future of video gaming is very bright...
...because game technology is bleeding into virtually every other industry...
...from military to homeland security, to health care, biotechnology, advertising, even news.
She says the federal government is spending millions of dollars on game technology...
...for training and recruiting personnel in various agencies.
For example, the US Army developed a series of video games called "America's Army".
The games, which can be downloaded free,...
...are designed to help young Americans explore careers in the army.